y más de 1.500 muertos en un solo día es
el balance que habrá si el registro el
jueves y que lo lleva a romper una
barrera que hasta ahora sólo eeuu había
pasado más de 200.000 fallecidos son dos
caras de una misma moneda la de luto y
esta otra de las playas de río de
janeiro llenas en diciembre aquí al
igual que en otras grandes urbes como en
sao paulo belo horizonte la ocupación
hospitalaria ha llegado al 90%
recientemente ante ese panorama habló el
presidente ya aire bolsonaro un crítico
del aislamiento social y que insiste en
mantener la economía funcionando
esperamos volver a la normalidad tan
pronto como sea posible la vida continúa
hoy lamentamos que hayamos llegado a los
200 mil muertos muchos de ellos con kobe
otros de kobe pero la vida sigue lo
sentimos mucho un guay punto que el
ministro de salud espera que la
vacunación empiece antes del 20 de enero
y ya se anunció la compra de las
primeras dosis colombia un país vecino
espera comenzar esta vacunación desde
febrero pero antes el gobierno nacional
adoptó un toque de queda para el próximo
fin de semana
un lunes feriado que rige para aquellas
ciudades con una ocupación de unidades
de cuidados intensivos superior al 70
por ciento esto afectará a un tercio de
los aproximadamente 50 millones de
habitantes del país la restricción a la
venta de alcohol o ley seca es otra de
las medidas que ha sido adoptada de
manera independiente por algunas
ciudades con miras a que en estos días
que son siempre desafiantes desde el
punto de vista de la logística nacional
nosotros tengamos la menor presión
posible sobre la expansión del uso de
unidades de cuidado intensivo el jugador
por su parte lamenta por tercer día
consecutivo más de mil contagios de
covite 19 la nación rechazó prohibir el
ingreso de los viajeros del reino unido
por miedo a la nueva variante de covite
19 de este país espera que las primeras
50.000 dosis de la vacuna desarrollada
por fácil variante -que lleguen a partir
del 18 de enero y comenzará así este
proceso con adultos mayores y personal
sanitario